Most of what we know
about performing leadership
is made up of these practiced postures
passed down in the West through a white,
male embodiment of power.
These have become so intertwined
with actually having power,
that imitating these behaviors
kind of feels like the only way
to show up with authority.
We can obviously do better than that.
I work in organizational
and leadership development
and I'm an artist.
I believe artists are leaders
in expressing things
that humankind often
doesn't know how to say yet.
So that's why I invited a bunch of artists
to do a leadership makeover.
They wrote public addresses.
They made leadership portraits.
I call them the Artists in Presidents.
(Laughter)
Since 2020,
over 70 Artists in Presidents
have contributed to the digital archive.
They're North American, Indigenous,
international and stateless,
they're artists with disabilities,
they're queer.
They made beautiful attempts at embodying
inclusive performances
of leadership and power.
Some sung,
others looked to repair the past,
one person used artificial intelligence
to write her speech,
and one person just
straight up wrote a curse.
And so many more.
But what really surprised me,
was that a lot of us struggled
to say something new.
To articulate what we want
with authority.
Blame it on the millennia
of humans colonizing humans,
but it seems like we don't believe
we can have the things we want.
The things that we need to live
and work with dignity.
So I think as leaders
interested in investing
in an equitable society,
modeling agency is one
of the most important things
that we can do for our communities
and organizations.
But it's hard.
How do you move towards
believing in your own agency?
The way that I learned to do this
came in a really unusual place.
When I was in my early 20s,
I met Captain Betsy.
I was queer, depressed,
feeling totally alone
in my tiny south Texas town
on the Gulf of Mexico.
And by the time Betsy landed in my town,
she had been living
on homemade rafts for decades,
with a group called
the Floating Neutrinos.
She had captained over a dozen rafts,
including one across the Atlantic Ocean.
In that thing.
(Laughter)
So the Floating Neutrinos believe
that the most important thing
a person needs to know how to do
is articulate their own desires.
To break out of being solely in reaction
to the systems that contain us,
like the economic system
and the education system.
So that we can allow our deepest desires
to be the thing that bring direction
and urgency to our lives.
The rafts were a tool
that the Neutrinos used
to bring themselves closer
to their desires.
So obviously, I was very taken by this,
not because I wanted
to permanently live on a raft,
but because I wanted to believe
in an extraordinary life.
And Betsy was the first
person to ever ask me
what it is that I wanted.
And she did this using a practice
called the three deepest desires.
She’d say, “Pretend you’re gonna die.”
You’re gonna die,
you’re all gonna die.
“Pretend that you’re
gonna die tomorrow.
What is one thing that you need
to do before you die?"
And then I would have full-on
drama meltdowns
around answering this question,
because it was impossible for me
to believe that I had any authority
over my own life.
That I could want things
outside of what my parents
and our culture had told us to want.
So Betsy finally said, "Look,
all you have to do
is answer this question for today.
You could say, 'I want to eat
the biggest hamburger in the world.'
OK, great. Whatever, write it down.
Because you're going to answer
this question again tomorrow
and it's how you answer this question
over time that matters."
And so then I said something
super weird, like,
"I want to see a waterfall,"
because there's no waterfalls
in south Texas.
And I got much better at it.
Saying what we want out loud
is something that we have to practice.
But the crux of this learning
is the believing part.
Believing. Faith.
It's not something
that we learn in isolation.
It's something that we learn
through imitation.
Like, leadership and language.
So in my life,
Betsy modeled for me what it meant
to articulate my desires
and in lending her faith to me,
she was also giving it back to herself.
But she did another thing.
And this is something
that leaders often forget to do.
She listened.
She sat with me
in the pain and discomfort of my process
and it's from that place,
my current reality,
that she guided me towards a vision
of possibility and agency in this world.
We can choose to model
our leadership styles in similar ways.
It's a commitment to relationality.
It's a process that never ends,
but it pays off because it grows
empowered, engaged
and inspired groups of people,
focused on a shared vision.
So if what we want
is to connect people's priorities
with our visions for the greater good,
we have to commit to mediating
between the truth that is in the room
and the aspirational future.
You’re all gonna die.
You could die tomorrow.
What's one thing that you want
to do before you die?
What kind of leader do you want to be?
Thank you.
(Applause)